[Música]
extendido en casi 130 kilómetros
cuadrados el puerto belga de amberes es
un lugar difícil de vigilar para las
autoridades se ha convertido en la
principal puerta de entrada a Europa el
año pasado se incautaron aquí más de 110
toneladas de cocaína un récord este
camión procedente Bulgaria pasa por el
escáner un tratamiento reservado solo a
una pequeña proporción del tráfico
en los controles del puerto de amberes
se inspeccionan entre uno coma cinco y
el 2% de los contenedores es la norma
europea pero queremos poder controlar a
más personas mediante la contratación y
la inversión en escáneres
al no encontrar nada sospechoso el
camión sigue su camino otros tendrán que
ser registrados
si hay una imagen sospechosa en el
escáner tenemos que investigar esa zona
[Música]
siempre
esta gente Busca productos falsificados
pero los funcionarios de aduanas también
conocen los signos reveladores de los
contenedores utilizados para ocultar
drogas como este descubierto hace unos
meses Esta es una carga típica de
bananos ahí se ven claramente sus formas
Pero el escáner muestra que la masa no
es la misma y ahí tenemos dos toneladas
de cocaína que han sido escondidas
un problema de contrabando que ha
manchado la reputación de esta ciudad a
principios de enero una niña de 11 años
Fue asesinada a tiros en un presunto
ajuste de cuentas relacionado con el
tráfico de drogas lloris es corresponsal
jurídico del periódico local y recibe
regularmente videos impactantes de
bandas criminales
no solo atacan las casas de los demás
sino que también lo filman porque en
realidad buscan la atención pública
alimentar más el terror y amenazar a sus
oponentes a sus enemigos
esta ciudad de 500.000 habitantes está
inmersa en una guerra contra las drogas
que ha desbordado el sistema
hay más delincuencia de la que nuestra
policía local y nuestro sistema judicial
pueden asumir realmente hay una crisis
en la capacidad de lo que las
autoridades locales pueden hacer contra
el problema
el problema de la drogadicción en
Bélgica se extiende Más allá de la zona
de amberes en la ciudad de lieja se Está
celebrando un juicio sin precedentes
a 37 acusados se les imputa por estar
involucrados en el tráfico internacional
de drogas Es la primera vez que este
abogado trabaja en un caso así
normalmente cuando eres abogado
penalista en una ciudad como lieja
te ocupas de la delincuencia de escala
menor
lidiando en las calles etcétera
aquí Hablamos más bien de importaciones
masivas
y al por mayor a través de los puertos
del norte de Europa
las autoridades han tenido que invertir
700.000 euros para asegurar la sala
ventanas blindadas presencia policial
reforzada
es una medida de seguridad de la que no
podíamos prescindir dado el nivel de
amenaza imagina que Ocurre algo
que matan a un magistrado o atacan uno
de los acusados
aunque cueste un poco de dinero creo que
nunca se es demasiado precavido
en 2021 el desmantelamiento de la
aplicación de mensajería cifrada es que
hay sc supuso la detención de numerosos
sospechosos de tráfico de drogas Gran
Victoria de la policía belga ahora le
toca a la justicia hacer un seguimiento
Cómo se puede hacer frente a
delincuentes que disponen de medios
absolutamente alucinantes a veces tienen
millones de euros en cuentas en
criptomoneda los que tienen medios
pueden comprar y desestabilizar todos
estos retos son completamente nuevos muy
diferentes de La amenaza terrorista por
ejemplo donde en última instancia los
medios implicados eran muy limitados a
medida que prospera el tráfico el
consumo de drogas se ha disparado el
análisis de las aguas residuales de casi
80 ciudades europeas reveló que amberes
era la ciudad con mayor concentración de
cocaína y Bruselas no se quedaba atrás
David es un exadicto que ahora ayuda a
quienes se enfrentan a la dependencia
según él el panorama de las drogas ha
cambiado hasta irreconocible
antes no había tanto tráfico no había
distribuidores que entregaran
directamente en tu salón a veces
teníamos que ir a Países Bajos para
conseguirlo
no era todo el mundo como hoy el entorno
ha cambiado mucho ahora es como Llamar a
una compañía de taxis
llamas y en un cuarto de hora tienes
droga mucha más gente tiene acceso
Este joven que prefirió permanecer en el
anonimato
vuelve a intentar dejar su adicción a la
cocaína todo un reto en una ciudad como
amberes donde es fácil encontrar drogas
en amberes es mucho más fácil está mucho
más disponible antes enviaba mensajes a
un número y al cabo de una semana
recibía mensajes de 10 números distintos
puedes elegir cualquier distribuidor fue
muy difícil en los periodos en los que
intentaban no consumir porque bloquea su
número y un par de días después recibes
un mensaje de otro número y eso te lo
detona es muy fácil enviar un mensaje y
media hora después está en tu Puerto
esta vez cambió de número antes de
empezar el tratamiento una precaución
ante un comercio ilegal cada vez más
profesional